each other corner I think it's my
ex-boyfriend you know things for doers
freaking out you know The Bachelor just
got about as awkward as The Bachelor can
get chase race is my ex-boyfriend yeah
on Monday night's episode Victoria F
went on a one-on-one date with Peter
while her ex-boyfriend chase rice
serenaded them and let's just say chase
he's not too happy about it either oh I
was really pissed off yeah here's what
went down
Victoria F got the one-on-one date with
pilot Pete but totally lost her when she
thought they were going skydiving you're
good I'm not kidding lucky for her they
didn't go skydiving but they did go for
a flight around Cleveland before hitting
up an amusement park where they went on
a ton of rides and Victoria F said no
about 1 million times
[Music]
like I've never seen someone hate a date
before tend to like it more well until
this happened
[Applause]
each are the corner I say case my
ex-boyfriend I'm not saying for doers
freaking out you know buckle up because
it's gonna be a bumpy ride a cuteness
chase things for Victoria F and Peter
Peter dances his sweet little heart out
completely unaware of what's going on
and chase the Victoria exchange some
heated looks he was singing to me and he
was like making these faces at me
because he told me
[Music]
Peter still blissfully unaware chats it
up with Chase and thanks him for coming
out
then Jason Victoria have a little chat
good concert though this whole thing
makes my skin itchy
after a lot of tears Victoria F
confesses to Peter what's going on Jason
I did yeah well Victoria says she broke
up with Chase because his lifestyle
didn't match up with hers and she wanted
to give it a try with Peter Peter says
it's weird but it's all good and
Victoria gets the rose happily ever
after right wrong chase recently weighed
in on the whole thing during a chat with
the Fitz in the morning podcast and guys
he totally downplayed his connection to
Victoria I've known her from we spent a
night together in Charlotte she's a cool
chick from what I know of her
they spent a night together okay you
guys refresher Victoria F said this
about their history together we dated
but I broke it off with him because his
lifestyle does that play match up to
what I want one plus one does not equal
two here people oh I was really pissed
off to be honest anyway chase said he
just wanted to go on the show and
promote his music there's anything I've
ever wanted to have nothing to do with
the drama of that show and even though
chase knew Victoria was on the show he
said he didn't expect to bump into her
oh my manager I'm a publicist that all I
know anymore about that they're not
gonna do that to you that's a weird
coincidence but they're not gonna
there's no where they would do that to
you to me
it's over-the-top it's unnecessary
auntie's seemingly blamed producers for
the whole awkward ordeal I didn't expect
it but in a day it happens so now that
Chase has dipped his toe in The Bachelor
pond would he ever join the show not a
shot now unless they take me a billion
dollars I'll do it for a billion dollars
so you're saying there's a chance
[Laughter]
so that's affirm know then but Peter
he's still all in this is gonna be very
difficult for me come forward he was on
the set of The Bachelor before this mess
went down and Peter admitted he was
already catching feelings just being a
few weeks into this early feeling very
strong feelings for some of the ladies I
don't think I expected that but then
again knowing me I know I fall hard and
I'm okay with that I think already he
can see that you know his wife is in
this room and he's gonna find love here
will it happen we don't know but he's of
such he's such a sincere guy he's truly
looking for something and right now all
signs are leading to hopefully a happy
ending The Bachelor really is just the
gift that keeps on giving
of course you can count on et to bring
you all the latest on Peter season so
make sure to keep it locked or right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
see you soon
[Music]